you've come out with an album I have I
have oh the Muppets and I went into the
studio to do this album we sort of got
lost ended up singing with a lot of
people and it made a nice album so we
put it all together lots of fun yeah
well I was gonna ask you about this this
is this is very risky very risky when
actors when actors try and sing you know
a Telly Savalas tried it you're kidding
yeah William Shatner Wow William Shatner
tried it a lot of people Leonard Nimoy I
think all of the Star Trek cast tried it
yeah it's it's very risky yeah well it
can't be risky sure but they're you know
I've actually been singing for years I
am kind of known as a singer as well as
an actor it's kind of a frog thing so to
swamp some time you'll hear her singing
I didn't realize that it was so talented
well that's very nice of you oh nothing
really
now I understand in part of this you're
in part of some you're actually seeing
with Ozzy Osbourne well I actually I
miss yes that's true that's true
Ozzy was around Miss Piggy actually sung
with Ozzy no Miss Piggy does yeah it's
very interesting Ozzy has a way with
barnyard animals who knew who knew
that's true
now I worked on the I worked on the I
was asked to be in the video I guess you
got a lot of people in the video we did
we got a whole long list of big
celebrities yes yes thanks and you were
great by the way thank you very much
everything I do but I was curious about
this I was backstage there and I I
sensed that there was a lot of tension
backstage Oh what you mean like like
lots of egos and stuff yeah it seemed
like a lot of you guys were very tense
and you're sort of you know success has
gone to your head yeah it happens
sometimes all right but I well you know
a lot of that was Miss Piggy
we told people to just check their egos
at the door but we couldn't find a
cheque room large enough for Piggy and
us to get a lot of problems with big
stars and now speaking of her are you
still an item with her you guys still
going out and I am no Conan I believe
you've been misinformed
you see there may I take this
opportunity on national television to
say Fox that there is nothing nothing
going on between Peggy and I other than
a purely professional relationship
no no really really a lot of us were
misled well I think that has a lot to do
with Miss Piggy being able to fax her
press releases directly to the National
Enquirer
I see now let me ask you something who
is she involved with is she seeing
anybody right now well there is that no
this is only a rumor mind you but I hear
that she has been seen around town with
Tom Arnold I would not mind I would not
mind at all she can do whatever she
likes it's okay with me I don't care
it's okay she's a pig what can I say oh
that's the 90s now when you can do
whatever they want sure and they can
even be pigs yes nothing there so I
don't wanna get littering
no no no one you're not gonna get no no
letters at all no letters at all
Kermit let me ask you I know that you
did you substituted for Johnny Carson
once that's true and you actually sat in
for it was a Larry King I did do that
one not long ago I was great fun yeah
well you actually so then you've had
quite a bit of experience this talk show
thing have you ever ever considered
doing your own talk show well I I
suppose if the opportunity presented
itself maybe I've been told that I look
sort of like a short green Regis Philbin
yeah maybe maybe it was fun doing the
Larry King thing it's kind of scary
though you know it goes liming you do
this every night but I'm just kind of a
simple forearm you know you seem to do
it well you're a very good
conversationalist well you are well okay
all right maybe I am maybe I should give
it a try sometime what do you think yeah
[Applause]
now you should have a show Wow thank you
I'd love to give it a try sure sure
anybody out there listening who has any
shows around just dinner plenty there
are plenty just walk around New York
I've heard that yes yeah all right now I
know that you're up on current events is
there anything you want you want to talk
about any current events at all that you
know you as a frog would like to comment
on well you know I try to be up on
current events but I've had a little
problem recently because I live in the
swamp and it's very hard to have a
television there it's kind of electrical
and water thing I so so the cables been
out you may be able to fill me in on a
few things I don't know no I couldn't
tell you a thing I don't watch TV you
don't to waste a valuable time well okay
let's look yeah yeah I'll go along with
that one I don't go along with that one
all right so yeah but you're enjoying
yourself everything's fine you've had a
good time in the album is there anything
else you want to say about the album
well it was a lot of fun alrights coming
out in a week or so and it's got all the
Muppets and we sing with people like as
you said Ozzy Osbourne one of my old
favorite I don't mean old I didn't mean
that cut that part one of my best
friends Linda Ronstadt oh very oh yes I
love Linda Ronstadt she's one of my
favorite people and and all those kind
of folks in all good singers good songs
excellent well listen well we're I want
to wish you the best of luck okay thank
you I will ask you next time you're on
the show would you sit in the chair
you saw what I can do in Bobcat
Goldthwait are the only two cups that up
there
oh really yeah at least I'm in good
company yeah you're in very good company
it's a it's a frog thing we have to go
you see that you look down on some of
your guests well yeah I just wanted to
be up here at eye level ah very nice
well listen Kermit thank you very much
for stopping by well it's been a
pleasure luck with the
you